[Musique]
l'inauguration d'un jardin partagé a eu
lieu ce lundi 22 août sur la commune de
La Possession dans le secteur de
Sainte-Thérèse 37 familles disposent
désormais de leur parcelle pour cultiver
fruits et légumes nous avons plusieurs
ambitions sur les jardins partagés on
participe à
la lutte contre la vie chère grâce aux
produits de ses jardins mais nous
participons aussi à une cohésion sociale
un retour au dialogue entre les voisins
et en participant à la vie de la cité
c'est un projet d'excellence
un jardin partagé d'une surface de 1500
m² au total qui a fait l'objet de
nombreux travaux permettant la pratique
de culture potagère un projet financé à
hauteur de 30% par le département dans
le cadre du pacte de solidarité
territoriale deuxième génération
terrassement donc plus la terre qui est
mise à disposition les parcelles la
création des différentes parcelles voilà
c'est les clôtures et les portails
d'entrée voilà tout cela était financé
par nos partenaires dont le département
on a à peu près 50% sur France relance
et un peu moins sur le PST2 donc sur un
total de 50 à 60 000 euros par jardin
pour les habitants du quartier en plus
d'améliorer la qualité de leur
alimentation ce jardin partagé permet de
créer du lien social et de la
convivialité
ah bah c'est clair que maintenant on se
croise un peu plus souvent on se connaît
un petit peu mieux on a on discute avec
nos voisins oui c'est clair alors
qu'avant c'est vrai que avant le jardin
partagé c'était c'était plus épisodique
c'est pas c'était plutôt rare même
c'était une opportunité pour nous
d'avoir un petit potager parce que on
n'a pas beaucoup de jardin chez nous
donc c'était l'occasion d'avoir un
espace qu'on pouvait consacrer à ça on
est déjà qu'elle mange ce que nous qu'on
produit nous et après de lui transmettre
ce savoir devenir arroser les plantes de
planter avec jardin
elle aime bien elle demande les clés
pour venir au jardin
ce jardin partagé situé dans le
lotissement de cap Noir et le quatrième
inauguré sur des terrains communaux à la
possession
[Musique]